معي هنا في استوديو مذيعه سابقه في قناه
العربيه وهي الان رئيس التحرير في قناه
الحدث سومار جابر وهذا دليل انه المذيعه
فيها هي تكون صانعه محتوى فبدي اقول انه
شكرا وشرف كتير كبير انه يكون معك اليوم
على شرف اكبر انه يكون معك واقول لكم
للصحفيين والصحفيات اللي بقولوا نحن مش
شكل وانما مضمون سومار هلا هي رئيس
التحرير سمار بالاول بدي اقول تغطيه حرب
تموز ولكن قبلها اهم شي كان اغتيال رفيق
الحريري حتى اللحظه هو اهم زعيم عربي
واغتال بهذه الطريقه كنتي على الهواء شو
صار وكيف دعت الخبر
كانت نشره عاديه واجا خبر انه في انفجار
ببيروت كنا عم نواكب نحنا بكل الاحوال
جلسه البرلمان اللي كان هو حاضر فيها وكان
في مشاكل اقتصاديه وسياسيه مثل ما بتعرفي
ريما بكل الاحوال بلبنان
وقت اللي قالوا انفجار ببيروت يعني ابعد
شيء عن ذهنك ينقال انه رئيس الحكومه رئيس
الحكومه مش عم بقول لانه لبناني رفيق
الحريري شخصيه عربيه معروفه وشخصيه دوليه
معروفه
عاده مثل ما انت عندك اللابتوب موجود في
انفجار بس ما حدا بيقول مين اللي استهدفوا
متل ما بتعرفي انت دايما بتسمعي المخرج
واذا في شيء البروديوسر هو اللي بقول لك
نحن بدنا نحط عاجل او في هذا الخبر لحتى
تكوني واثقه انت من ذاتك وتقوليه
سمعت صوت بيقول لي انقتل رفيق الحريري ما
يعني هي قصه ما عم بقول وقت هي خمس ثواني
لن اتطلعت على اللاب توب ما في حدا جايب
سيره انه على الوكاله على
السكرين كمان ما في عاجل بس كان هذا سبا
انه بغض النظر سبا ممكن يكون خبر جميل جدا
وممكن يكون خبر محزن جدا بس سبق الصحفي
سبا صحفي ما رديته وكملت هاليوم ان تكون
شخصيه لبنانيه
مستهدفه على الهواء كان غسان مكحل بواجه
له تحيه
فساعتها وقت اللي يعرفوني انه انا مزعت
الخبر لان الصوت اللي سمعته مش صوت
البروديوسر والضجه بقلب الهيدا فانا بدي
اتاكد لان هيدا منه خبر قليل
بسمع ساعتها شخص بيقول لي انا عبد الرحمن
الراشد قولي تم اغتيال رئيس الحكومه رفيق
الحريري وقت قتل ساعتها قلت بس بدون اي
شعور
وقتها تغير مجرى تاريخ بلبنان يمكن نشره
التاريخ بلبنان وكان سلسله بمجرى التاريخ
بالعالم العربي اللي شفتني كتير يعني في
حديث كتير عن حرب تموز كمان بس بهالسيا
بدي اذكر زميله نجوى قاسم هي صديقتك وراح
يكون في اليوم لها محط بس حابه انا شخصيا
احكي معك عن نجوى اولا لو ما نجوى ما قدرت
تطلع على الجنوب كنت انا ما اخذت فرصه
المهنيه هذه الفرصه حطتني على خارطه
الاعلام لكن نجوى هي الغائب الحاضر لا
تغيب
فبدي اقول لك شو بتقولي لا لن نجوى هيك لو
كانت معنا لان كان بيلبق لها تكون معنا
بهيك نهار بيربق لا بس
روحها معنا
بيلبق لها لانه مش غايبه عنه بس كنت مذيعه
اساسيه بيلبق لك كانت هي استضافتنا
مش نحن عم نحكي عنه
وكانت مذيعه رئيسيه شو كان مهم انه تشوفي
مذيع رئيسه مثل نجوى قاسم نازله مراسله
ميدانيه نجوى مش مذيعه مع كل احترامي نجوى
مذيعه شاشه نجوى صحفيه صحفيه ارض ومش
صحفيه لبنانيه طيب حتى موز عم نحكي عن
نجوى لان كان حرب تموز كمان من المحطات
القاسيه الاساسيه اللي غطت فيها الى اي
درجه موضوع حرب تموز ايضا
برعت في قناه العربيه لانه اخذت خط تحريري
مختلف عن باقي القنوات بس هو كان الخط
مش لان انا من العربيه ولا لاني صحفيه او
بنت العربيه بس هو الخط المختلف اللي عم
تحكي عنه اللي كان مع الشعب اللبناني
الدايركت بس كان انه هذا الحرب ليه وهذا
دمار ليه والقتله
قدره العربيه تبين انه هذا الخط الصحيح
اللي هي مشيت فيه حرب تموز بالنسبه
للعربيه كان مفصل تحريري صادق مش لان انا
فيها انا بنت جنوب لبنانيه كنت عم بغطي
وعم ابكي كانوا اهلي بالجنوب بس كنت عم
باول
13 و14 ساعه وكل بين فتره وفتره اذا لقط
معي تليفون بدي اطمن عن اهلي بس كنت راضيه
عم ينقال لان تغطيه نهر البارد كمان تغطيه
المهمه بلبنان وطبعا لحقها كتير من
الاحداث الاساسيه انفجار مرفق بيروت
البريكي نيوز اللي اجى الى اي درجه بتقدري
كل لبنانيه كمواطنه من هالبلد وصحافيه
تقدري تغطي احداث هالقد مصيريه
بموضوع لبنان بموضوع لبنان بتقدر تغطي
لانك انت بنت لبنان بتعرفي الزواريب يعني
عم بحكي اليوم شوي
السياسه اللبنانيه زويريه وشوارع وطرقات
اللي ما بيعرفها بده يشوف فيها لانه هن
متوهين بس الاهم انه متل ما بتقدري تغطي
بلبنان درنا نغطي بشوارع تانيه بدول تانيه
وانت قادره يعني ريما غطيتي كل شي من
لبنان لبرا لبنان واي صحفي عنا عمل هيك
شكرا وانا بدي استسكي كمان ساعه سيلاوي
الله يرحمه كمان اللي اخادرونا لكن بقيوا
معنا بيروحون سمار بذكر كانت مذيعه بقناه
العربيه وهي اليوم رئيس التحرير وهذا دليل
اخر على انه الناس تيجي لهون وبتبقى كل
عام وانتم بخير شكرا كثير شكرا الك
للمشاركه ميرسي
فاصل قصير ونعود معكم ابقوا معنا
ثانكيو كانت اوكي
بهذا ذكرى العشرين لانشاءها
ومتمنية لها ولكل الفريق مزيد من النجاح
والاشعاع على المستوى العربي والمستوى
الدولي طلبت كل العربية موجوده كان
المفروض انشاها لان منذ انشاء من قبل 20
سنه يعني
اثرت المشهد الاعلام العربي
[موسيقى]
بين بدايه ونهايه
احداث متلاحقه تمر في وقت
[موسيقى]
لا يقف
لا يتباطا
لا يرجع للوراء
احداث نلاحقها في اماكنها عند وقوعها على
مدار الساعه
فقط
لنخبر عنها
[موسيقى]
نحن لا نملك الوقت نحن فقط نخبر عن اخبار
الساعه من الاحد الى الخميس 11 على الشاشه
العربيه
اما موضوع اللاجئين كان في معادله
[موسيقى]
بموسم
في 15 سنه القادمه
هل تشع
رون حذاء خذلتكم
على الحرب اذا عرض عليك رئيس بوتين
بالتنحي مقابل وقف الحرب ممكن ان تقبل ذلك
من الرعب الذي اثاره فيروس كورونا في
العالم وتعطيله لحياه البشر لفترات صعبه
الى اثاره تعصف بالداخل الامريكي كل اربعه
اعوام مع السباق الرئاسي وغير غير ذلك
الكثير دائما كانت العربيه معكم في تغطيات
مختلفه وموسعه على كافه منصاتها باحدث
التقنيات التلفزيونيه نتابع
فيروس تخشى الدول حاليا من انتشاره هو
قادم من الصين وسبع مئه حاله حتى الان
جميع الاوساط العلميه اللي تتكلم عن
الفيروس كورونا الجديد اعلنوا حالتي طوارئ
عالميه بسبب تفشي فيروس كورونا وعدد من
دول العالم تسجل اصابات جديده
طلبت منظمه الصحه العالميه العالم بالتاهب
لمحاربه الفيروس يجب ان نسرع تطوير
اللقاحات والتشخيص
اعلان فيروس كورونا وباء رسميا
الاف شخص بعد اعلان اسبانيا تسجيل
كيف هي تطورات ما الذي يحكم من عندك انتاج
الكمامات الطبيه حيث تعاني هونج كونج
بالنقص حاد فيها العاصمه 120 حاله مؤكده
انا لن البس الكمامه
كنا يد
خلون غير مرضى هو الفيروس المرعب الذي
يربك العالم كورونا
[موسيقى]
محاولات عده للاقتراب من الباخره الموبئه
دائما برنسس
[موسيقى]
التغذيه تاتيكم من هنا العربيه الخارجيه
مراكز الاختراع فتحت طباعه
[موسيقى]
نتناول تفاصيل كثيره في الانتخابات
الامريكيه في الصحفيين منذ لحظات تحدث عن
فلوريد
مواقع التواصل بالفعل مشاهدينا متهمه من
وقت الانتخابات الماضيه بالانتخابات
الرئاسيه
[موسيقى]
كانت المؤشرات سجلت ارتفاعات
استقاله وشيكا للرئيس الافغاني اشرف غني
عشرين عام تريليون دولار 2500 جندي ضحيه
وخروج بهذه الطريقه من افغانستان وعوده
طالبان لاحتلال كل افغانستان ما الذي
استفادته امريكا
اقف هنا في المنطقه الشماليه من مطار
كابول نحن هنا في القسم العسكري وقد سمحت
طالبان لنا بالتصوير في هذا المكان
في العاصمه الافغانيه كابول تقديرات
الامريكيه كانت تشير الى ثلاث شهور لسقوط
كابول اتخذ خيارًا صعبا فكانت المواجهه او
المغادره
[موسيقى]
معي من بيروت الكاتب الصحفي سامي منسه سام
اهلا بك انت ضيف دائم على قناه العربيه في
الكثير من الملفات كنا نستضيفك بالملف
تخطيط الانتخابات الامريكيه او الشان
الامريكي بشكل عام وسياسات امريكا في
المنطقه او في المنطقه وايضا في موضوع
لبنان
والملفات الاخرى لاي مدى العربيه بعشرين
عام تمكنت من اعطاء وجهه النظر الاخرى في
ضوء
الضغط الاعلامي من قبل باقي المحطات يعني
القدر نارتف الذي قدمته قناه العربيه
بالاساس ريما اهنيكم على العشرين سنه
النقطه الثانيه والاساسيه انه العربيه هي
حياه خطوه رائده بالاعلام العربي من
العشرين سنه اللي مرق فيهم الاعلام العربي
باسوا مراحل لسيا انه خلال العشرين سنه
كان الاعلام اللبناني الذي كان رائدا في
هذا المجال كان قد يعني رحمه الله توفي
العربيه
ومجموعه من وسائل الاعلام
يعني الاعلام العربي يعني نقلي بشهداء
القرن الماضي والقرن الحالي لقلت الاعلام
العربي من اعلام محلي غير حيادي غير قادر
على يعني
الاعلام تميزت فيه العربيه هو اعلام غير
حيادي انما موضوعي لا استطيع ولا يعني ولا
تريد للعربيه ولا غيرها ان تكون حياديه بل
كان موضوعيه من هون برجع لتغطيه الى سؤالك
انه النقل بالنسبه لموضوع الولايات
المتحده التي مرت بحالات من القرب من
السياسات العربيه واحيانا من البعد عن
السياسات العربيه تمكنت العربيه من
استضافه وتوضيح وجهات النظر
الامريكيه الى العالم العربي يعني اللي
فاهمه بشكل خارج عن هذا
السرديه
المعتاده في الاعلام العربي انه كل ما هو
امريكي سيء هي هذه يعني هيدا هذه الطريقه
سهله جدا
بكسب المؤيدين انه نحن ضد كل شيء بس لاي
مدى ايضا تغطيه العربيه للانتخابات
الامريكيه او حتى لسياسات امريكا في
المنطقه اعطت البعد الاخر لما يجري على
الارض يعني
كما هي انا
غطيت
العربيه في استوديو في دبي بمرحب
بانتخابات وكان من ضيوف العربيه في
انتخابات داله من بيروت من خلال الانترنت
في
الحالتين العربيه كانت تعرف وجهه نظري في
الانتخابات وعلى الرغم من ذلك كانت
تستضيفني
وهذا نقطه اساسيه
بتغطيات العربيه اللي بتكرر وبقول انها
كانت تضع او تقدم وجهات النظر كافه
الموجوده لتغطيه موضوعيه للحدث على الرغم
انه قد يكون عنده مراحل معينه وجهات نظر
مختلفه عن ضيوفها وهذاك ثمن لهذه وجهات
النظر يعني انا اتذكر بالتغطيه حرب تموز
العربيه روت الامور كما هي ليس فقط بتصوير
انه حزب الله هو المقاوم ضد اسرائيل
والشعبويه وكان صعب على قناه الحديث عن
شيء غير شعبوي
برايك
بهاي النقطه بالذات لما قلت انه العربيه
لم تكن هي ليست محطه حياديه انما موضوعيه
اهميتها انه مثلا قدرت العربيه خلال
كل مراحل ادوار ايران في المنطقه وادوار
حزب الله في المنطقه وفي لبنان ان تغطي
تغطي اول شيء للحدث ترطي صحفي اعلاميه
ايضا كانت قادره على ان توضح
يعني
ثبوت تلقي الضوء على النقاط السلبيه
والاساسيه في ادوار حزب الله في لبنان وفي
المنطقه وهذا ما تراكاش ما بعرف شو
بالعربي كلمه تركيز الاعلامي انا كمان ما
عرفت كمان ترجمه سؤال اخير عربيه اخذت نعم
كانت بتغطيات مهمه العربيه بموضوع ايضا
تغطيه كل الامور التي تتعلق بالارهاب
ناهيك عن الامور اللي بتتعلق بالميليشيات
بالعالم العربي ما خطوره ذلك على الصحفيين
وعلى المراسلين على الارض برايك مع خطوره
هذا الخط التحريري
يعني الخطوره اول شيء كل الصحفيين
بهاد مع اطراف مثل الاطراف التي نواجهها
سواء كانوا من الاطراف الذين يعني ياخذون
الارهاب على الطريقه الايرانيه او الارهاب
على الطريقه الداعشيه والقاعديه وهذه طبعا
يعني واضح واضح جدا انما بالاساس اهميه
الادوار التي قامت بها برجع بكرر وتقول
هذا الاهميه اليوم بالذكرى العشرين
العربيه انه العربيه والوسائل الاعلام
القريبه منها اللي ذكرت صفحات الراي في
بعض وسائل الاعلام المرئيه مثل حياه كانت
بالشرق الاوسط اليوم مثل العربيه مثل ام
بي سي كانت القوه الناعمه للعرب في اعطاء
صوره مغايره ومختلفه وجديه عنهم اللي هي
ما كانت موجوده حتى بين
الاعلام اللبناني اللي كان رغم كل
اعلام محلي لم يكن اعلام بانورام مثل هلا
اليوم بنقول الاعلام هذا الاعلام هو اعلام
عربي وليس لا سعودي ولا يمني ولا فرنساوي
ولا الماني ولا لبناني ولا غير واعتقد ان
منارت الاعلان تنتقل الى رياض قريبا لم
تعد لا ببيروت ولا بالقاهره كما كانت مع
بدايه انتشار الاعلام والصحافه شكرا جزيلا
لك من بيروت كان معي الكاتب الصحفي سامي
مناسا شكرا دائما وتبقى دائما منور على
الشاشه شاشه العربيه
لا حدود لما يمكن ان يصبح عناوين الاخبار
وغالبا لا توقعات بشانها فمن طفل مغربي
يخطف انظار العالم يومين ثم تنتهي القصه
بنهايه حزينه الى حرب شغلت العالم في
اوكرانيا وليس انتهاء بماسات هزت تركيا
وسوريا مؤخرا في كل هذه الاحداث وغيرها
كانت العربيه حاضره وكنتم انتم مشاهدينا
على موعد اخر مع وما وصلت اليه عواقب هذه
الاحداث
[موسيقى]
اليوم الاول من الغزو الروسيه لاوكرانيا
لم يتركوا لنا اي خيار روسيا استخدمت كل
وسائل الاعتداء
معدات التي تمر من هنا هي معدات روسيه
[تصفيق]
تتطاير حول
ومن قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لدعم
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الخارجيه الصينيه تقول باننا نراقب الوضع
في اوكرانيا عن كثب عبد الجواده رشد ومن
كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
اخر التحديثات في موسكو نحو 200 نقطه
عسكريه ستكون العربيه شاهده على مناورات
هذه محطه المياه الخاصه بمدينه جرينجا هذا
الامس كنا نشير الى 58 موقعا تم اسعافهم
طفلان وسته بالغين
هذه التغطيه المتواصله من العربيه
لمحاولات انقاذ الطفل ريان
[موسيقى]
تحدث والدتي تتفاعل في العربيه
من الامطار بعمليه يمكن الدورات الاخيره
امال الانتظار صاحبها حزن كبير مع اعلان
وفاه ريان
[موسيقى]
اعلان رسمي عن وفاه ملكه بريطانيا
اليزابيث الثانيه
[موسيقى]
الى هذه التغطيه المستمره لليوم الذي يوصف
باليوم التاريخي اليوم طوت لندن صفحه من
تاريخها عيون العالم كلها الان على لندن
في اكبر حدث
دبلوماسي اكبر حدث امني بوجود قاده من حول
العالم رؤساء ملوك امراء لحضور جنازه
الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه ربما حتى مليون
شخص توافدوا على هذا المكان جنازه ستشهد
اكبر عمليه امنيه في بريطانيا هل كانت كل
صفحات الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه مضيئه ام
لا
[موسيقى]
المعهد الامريكي يقول ان زلزالا بقوه ثمان
درجات يضرب جنوب تركيا
وقع زلزال في منطقه بازار تشيك
سبع درجات هذه التغطيه مستمره على شاشه
العربيه وصور مختلفه لاثار الدمار ومن
اكثر من منطقه نواصل معكم هذه التغطيه
المباشره والمستمره من استديوهات العربيه
هنا في الرياض دمار كامل في هذه المدينه
الان
غير قادرين على انقاذ ضحايا الزلزال
قفز عدد قتل الزلزال المدمر وسط ظروف صعبه
جدا للطعام وللمنامه ومع دخولنا اليوم
الرابع
طبعا مشاهد مؤلمه نتيجه هذا الزلزال
التركيه تحدث الارقام
اود ان اتقدم باحر التهاني لهذه القناه
التي اثرت الفضاء الاعلامي العربي
واتمنى لها مزيد من النجاحات لما فيه خير
والاضافه
للعمل الاعلامي المتواصل بما يخدم اناره
الراي العام العربي بصفه عامه
احلى سنين العمر كانت بهالعشرين سنه وكانت
بتستاهل التغطيه مستمره ميسون نويهد وزميل
جواد كاظم ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
الاخباريه من قناه العربي
[تصفيق]
وفي خبر عاجل منذ قليل ثلاثه عراقيين من
الاسواق العربيه الى الاعلام تواخذ الدقه
يصل المدير العام للوكاله الشيخ رائد
القاضي وزير الخارجيه الايراني
اهلا بكم معنا نبدا اخبار الليله
[موسيقى]